I never realized until now how much she
was my North Star as well and right now
things seem a lot less bright and
magical without her Anderson Cooper
getting choked up on his first show back
on CNN since the death of his mom Gloria
Vanderbilt the American icon died on
June 17th at the age of 95 after a brief
battle with cancer being able to spend
those nine days and nights with her was
a great great blessing they were the
most extraordinary days of my life
and I'm very grateful in a nearly
five-minute eulogy for his mother
Anderson noted how she was the only true
family member he had left his dad died
when Anderson was 10 his brother when he
was 21 they're all gone and it feels
very lonely right now I hope they are at
least together Anderson called his mom
his best friend the pair authored the
book the rainbow comes and goes together
in 2016 which was turned into an HBO
documentary called nothing left unsaid
this will be fascinating terrain for
secrets she's revealed things even to me
in the last couple weeks that I had no
idea about and so it was it was kind of
amazing it that even after all this time
even though we know each other very well
there's a whole lot of secrets that came
up hearing up in this film that I really
had no idea I'm happy that we left
nothing unsaid between us she knew me
and I knew her and there was great
comfort in that
you